these prototype gloves turn colors when
they detect harmful chemicals in the air
and a vaccine to treat the relapse of
heroin addiction has been proven
effective in drug-addicted rats and
they'll soon begin work on human trials
Vsauce Kevin here this is mine a
six-inch skeleton found 10 years ago in
Chile has finally been proven to be
human remains and not as some had
claimed an alien
Gary Nolan immunologist at Stanford
University discovered the DNA was modern
and high-quality indicating that it's
only a few decades old it undoubtably
human he concluded that the bones were
around the age of six to eight years old
and he hypothesizes that he or she died
in the womb and suffered from a rapid
aging disorder or less likely lived with
a severe form of dwarfism to that age
tweet P lets parents know when their
baby has peed using a device that
measures moisture and looks like a
Twitter bird it's been developed for
Huggies diapers in Brazil the sensor
measures the wetness and alerts parents
with a tweet or text message when their
baby has eight Terrafugia of
massachusetts is working on making a
flying car for the everyday person the
tf-x will take off vertically like a
helicopter than once in the air rotor
blades drop and a rear-mounted gas
engine takes over the computer in the
car is programmed to land it for you and
there's an emergency parachute if needed
it has a nonstop flight range of 500
miles and should only take five or so
hours for the average person to learn
how to use they expect to start selling
it around 2020 and assume the price will
be similar to any high-end luxury car
brightest explosion ever observed
students from Royal College of Art in
London developed a set of headphones
that can enhance the users sight and
hearing one device is a mask that sits
over the mouth and ears where a
directional microphone captures audio
and is processed to neutralize
background noise it's then passed
through to the listener so it's as if
someone is talking inside your
applications are for the
hearing-impaired and possibly to help
children with ADHD focus in classrooms
the second fits over the eyes and allows
the user to see special effects head
mounted cameras capture imagery where
it's processed and played back to the
wearer
applications will be helpful for sports
teams and performing arts the bounce
imaging Explorer helps first responders
evaluate dangerous situations before
having to go in themselves it has a
shock absorbing shell with six cameras
LEDs to light up dark rooms and a
digital microphone after singing it with
a smartphone or tablet you throw the
ball into the dangerous area it
immediately begins taking pictures and
testing for toxins and high temperatures
noose undo species of meat eating plant
found in Japan Xerox plans on rolling
out ignite a service that turns copiers
scanners and Printers into paper grading
machines and not only will it be able to
grade papers like the commonly used
scantron system it will have the ability
to turn right and wrong answers into
web-accessible data which will let
teachers know whether a student or group
of students are consistently having
trouble with certain math problems
making it easier for the teacher to plan
lessons and help specific students in
certain areas and tailoring homework to
their academic strengths and weaknesses
the Palas long-tongued bat eats using a
really long blood swollen tongue they
have tiny hairs along their tongues that
engorge with blood when they need to get
nectar from a plan the hairs act sort of
like a mob grabbing as much nectar as
possible with each swipe previously
biologists thought the hairs were
inactive and just sat there but recent
studies have shown that they're very
active and the process is the same that
makes male reproductive organs erect in
mammals finally Vincent and Emily are a
robotic couple made as an examination of
human relationships that reacts to
signals around them
I'm gonna leave you with a new legged
leaping robot and as always thanks for
watching